so the jesse smelly trial continues you
remember that time
that uh jesse sommelier um
claimed that a couple of mega-hatted
white supremacists attacked him on the
streets of chicago at three o'clock in
the morning in the middle of a wind
storm
and um and tried to put a noose around
his neck and then it turned out all that
was bullcrap and he just hired a couple
of guys to do it
allegedly
well now he's on trial for lying to the
cops and putting together this whole
ridiculous situation in the first place
according to the associated press former
empire actor josie smith denied monday
that he staged an anti-gay racist attack
on himself testifying at his trial there
was no hoax and he was the victim of a
hate crime in his downtown chicago
neighborhood
now
the the hate crime that he says happened
was um from his friends sommelier it's
actually i think it's pronounced millet
right
but we will continue to pronounce the
smellier because it's funnier smogier
who faces charges he lied to chicago
police about the january 2019 attack
sought to refute damaging testimony from
two brothers last week
they said smelly who is gay and black
orchestrated the hoax to get publicity
giving them hundred bucks for supplies
instructing them to place a noose around
his neck and yell homophobic slurs they
also said sommolier gave them a 3 500
check to carry it out
smollett appeared calm throughout
several hours of testimony saying he
wrote the 3 500 check to abim bolo
asundero for nutrition and training
advice
asked by his defense attorney if he gave
asundero a payment for some kind of hoax
smollett replied never
attorney nene uche asked again if he
planned to hoax no smulette said there
was no hoax he also said absolutely not
when asked if he gave osandero and his
brother a hundred bucks to pay for
supplies for the fake attack
smollett told jurors he had just
returned from a trip and was walking
home after buying a sandwich around 2
a.m on january 29 2019 when someone
yelled a racist homophobic remark
smollett said he turned around to
confront the person who he said towered
over him
standing up in the chicago courtroom
smellette demonstrated how he said the
man walked quickly toward him then
pointed to his left temple to show where
the man hit him i would like to think i
landed a punch but i don't know if it
landed simolette said he said he slipped
and they tussled on the ground for up to
30 seconds that was like the story of
jacob wrestling with the angel from the
bible except for this guy is lying and
hired somebody to to do this smellette
said he saw a second person who he
believes kicked him on the side and that
person ran away
smilet said he assumed the person who
attacked him was white because he used a
racial slur and shouted mega country an
apparent reference to president donald
trump's campaign slogan
the brothers
bimbola and ola bingo asundero who are
black testified last week smellette
instructed them to yell this is mega
country during the fake assault which of
course makes more sense considering
chicago is not mega country you cannot
find a less mega country place than
chicago
smolette said he picked up his phone and
told the person he had been talking to
that he got jumped he testified he
noticed he had a noose around his neck
as he returned to his apartment
smelled said he removed the news but a
friend who was at the apartment called
the cops and told him to put the noose
back on so officers could see it
you have to show the officers of a noose
around your neck please put it back on
jesse
smallett said he was upset police had
been called because he would have never
done so
i am a black man in america i do not
trust the police malette said i am also
a well-known figure at that time and i'm
openly gay
wow wow wow wow so you staged the whole
thing and then he's like i would never
call the cops because the cops are
racist bigot homophobes just like those
guys who i may or may not have had a
sexual relationship with who i then
hired to um to do this
because that is the the other part of
the story we'll get back to more on
jessie's merlier in just one second
first it's that time of year to start
shopping for your friends and family and
let me tell you you need to start your
shopping over at raycon raycons they
give you the amazing audio quality you
need wherever you go whether you're
using them to pump up wind down to work
or work out they'd be useful for anyone
on your list even better for you they
started half the price of other premium
audio brands raycon offers eight hours
of playtime a 32-hour battery life and
raycons are available in five stylish
colors so you can pick a perfect one for
everyone on your list there's also a
built-in mic you can take calls on your
earbuds at the press of a button with
free shipping and returns giving them is
easier than ever so check these babies
out these raycons look at this this is
just a beauty
here are the raycons you just pop this
sucker open take out the raycons
ah that perfect fit
and the sound glorious right now my
listeners can get 15 off their raycon
order all you have to do is click the
link in the description box or go to buy
recon dot com shapiro yt use code
holiday to get 15 off site wide that's
by raycon.com shapiro yt code holiday to
save 15 off raycons
smolette said after news broke that
everyone including trump had an opinion
about what happened he hated the
attention yes i'm sure he hated the
attention jesse smilet
he was desperate yes he was hating it
under cross examination smelled said he
refused to give chicago police his cell
phone because he wanted his privacy
asked by special prosecutor dan webb if
he was concerned the phone would show
calls to abimbola oscendero smolette
said no
smellette also testified asundero told
him he could get an herbal steroid that
encourages weight loss but is illegal in
the us on the low
while he was on an upcoming trip to
nigeria
asundero testified that millet sent him
a text message about talking on the low
and that during the conversation smelled
asked him about helping to stage the
attack someone said monday the message
was in reference to the illegal steroid
when webb asked about osandero's
testimony that's millett recruited him
for the hoax said fully false one
hundred percent false
smellette's lawyers say chicago police
rushed to judgment when they brought
charges against millet
someone said he met abimbola asundera it
was a meet cute and they they met in
2017 at a club where he learned asundera
also worked on the empire set
he said the two men did drugs together
went to a bath house where smallett said
they made out he said they did more
drugs and participated in sex acts
together asendera testified last week
he and smallett did not have a sexual
relationship
smallett testified he met abhimbola's
brother but they didn't speak
he said abimbola made it sound like they
needed to sneak off when they were
together around his brother
and smell it said he never trusted ola
bingo
[Music]
prosecutors say that smilet staged the
attack because he was unhappy with
empire's response to hate mail he
received
the letter he the letter included a
drawing of a stick finger stick figure
hanging by a news with a gun pointed at
it and the word magga
uh by the way the chance is that
smolette sent that letter to himself
i am going to speculate okay
um yeah i don't think that that's real
either
security guard anthony moore said around
the time of the alleged assault he saw a
person on the ground at the end of the
block and two men running one of them
was white
moore said he told the cops what he saw
when he was later questioned by a
special prosecutor he felt pressured to
change his story
more testified he signed a statement
that said the person was possibly a
black man but that he felt pressure and
threatened to put something out there i
didn't see
under cross examination moore said he
only saw the man for one to two seconds
and he thought the men were fooling
around and two men were laughing as they
ran by him
so
yeah things went really well for the
jesse's mullet testimony really really
well done here by the way how stupid is
our culture the current vice president
of the united states still has a tweet
up about her sympathy for jesse smolette
good times good times there
see here's the thing justice milette
wanted his story to be the story about
what america is his actual story is what
america is a bunch of people clamoring
for attention by faking victimhood that
is what america currently is in 2021 it
is not a place where black men are
routinely attacked by maggie hatted
racist on the streets of chicago at 2am
it is a place where people fake that
sort of thing so they can get attention
and most of the time
it falls apart and some of the time they
get away with it
so just uh
genius stuff there from jesse's mullet
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video